every once in a while i like to come
back to what is a really
disturbing reality in the united states
which is the tax exempt uh nature not
only of sort of like churches generally
or
of the schools within churches but even
radical extremist dangerous churches
having this benefit from the government
wherein they do not pay taxes of many
kinds including sometimes taxes on the
properties that they own
income taxes on proceeds received etc
etc etc and there is really no better
example of this
than global vision bible church in
tennessee where if that sounds familiar
we have talked about it before where
pastor greg locke recently went on an
outrageous febrile screed
uh where he said not only are there six
bonafide witches in our congregation
he said three of them are in the room
right now
okay this is this is sanctioned
by the state
in the sense that it is a tax-exempt
endeavor
take a look at this
we got first
and last names
of six witches
that are in our church and you know what
strange three of you are in this room
right now
right
three of you in the room right now
you better look in my eyeballs we ain't
afraid of you you stinking witch you
devil worshiping satan this witch this
is this is dark ages stuff
this is dark ages
think about the track record of the
united states when it comes to
accusations of witchcraft right i mean
there's there's precedent here and this
is reminiscent of a very very bad time
in salem massachusetts we cast you out
in the name of jesus christ we break
your spells we break your curse we got
your first name we got your last name we
even got an address for one of you
now the address part should frighten all
of us because um
you know i mean listen you don't need to
think too far about what is being
threatened when you when you say address
now it's easy to write this off as this
is one lunatic and of course
it is a lunatic but this is a tax-exempt
church
and he's making open threats here on you
know which witchcraft give me a break
guys
you so much as cough wrong and i'll
expose you in front of a body in this
tent you stinking witch
you were sent to this church to destroy
us you were sent to this church to lure
us in you were sent to this church to
cast spell listen some of you been sick
cause you befriended that witch
blaming but that's by the way
this is a this is a coveted crazy guy
um he called kova to fake pandemic in
december of 2020.
he turned on trump when trump started
saying hey the vaccine's pretty good
completely turned on trump at that time
so what he's even saying there is
those of you who think you got coveted
you have to understand the the what this
guy's talking about those of you who
believe you got covet that you you were
sick you had symptoms
it wasn't covered it was witchcraft two
of you in my wife's latest bible study
and you know who you are and we gonna
ask you to get out
or i'll expose you in front of everybody
we got all six of their names
all six of them
two of them had already been confirmed
for that thing everyone said it
first and last night this chick is new
to our church and don't know none of you
so you got a choice
you can leave with your spells
all by yourself
or i'll show up next sunday
with a stage full of brooms
and i'll give you one and i'll fly your
tail up out of this place in the name of
jesus but we ain't playing your spell
casted witchcraft nonsense now of course
you know if we want to take this uh
pragmatically we would all be saying you
know
if you're praying to jesus the right way
isn't that stronger than the witchcraft
like can't do you need to kick them out
to resist the spells or could you maybe
just pray right and then god will
protect you from this who's stronger the
witches
it none of it makes sense
this is a guy
who's running a church
with a transphobic homophobic climate
change denying covet-denying record
he posted a video back in august of 2020
threatening violence against the dunkin
donuts employee who he referred to as
nazi skippy because the employee was
like hey we have a mask policy here
we got it you got to wear a mask here
global vision bible church in tennessee
tax exempt think about how backwards
this all is
in the united states
the trump family doesn't have a great
track record when it comes to charity
and donations
trump often promising donations which he
never gives
we've talked about the trump uh
foundation or whatever it was called
having to stop operating as part of an
agreement based on an investigation into
the fraudulent nature of that well
melania trump is now getting pulled into
it a melania trump event is being
investigated after promising to donate
proceeds to a charity uh-oh
that doesn't appear to exist
um a charity event set to be hosted by
melania in florida is being investigated
after organizers said a portion of its
proceeds would go to a charity that does
not appear to exist per the new york
times
the organizers have set the high tea
event in april in naples florida will
benefit fostering the future a b best
initiative granting computer science
scholarships to those aging out of the
foster care system tickets are three
grand vip tickets are 50 grand we don't
know what percentage would go to charity
but what's the real problem the real
problem is the new york times found no
charity with the name fostering the
future or be best registered in florida
now you might say well maybe they're
just not registered but in florida the
law requires that organizations
soliciting donations
register so that you know it's a real
charity
consumer services division is currently
investigating whether this event
involves an entity operating in
violation of chapter 496
florida statutes
melania trump
denies that the charity doesn't exist
the new york times of course reported
this initially and uh people following
up
following the launch of her line of nfts
and the auction of a white hat she wore
at the white house she's selling tickets
for this april 9th event in naples
the tulips and topiaries high tea is
pitched as a once in a lifetime
experience an afternoon of sophisticated
elegance set in elaborate lush floral
gardens designed to inspire giving hope
possibility and dreams
um
there's no indication of how much money
will be raised
uh and melania says the reporting that
the charity doesn't exist is false she
tweeted dishonest reporting added again
everything has been done lawfully and
all documents are in the works read with
caution typical corrupt media she added
she's working with the bradley impact
fund which calls itself a donor-advised
fund
for
conservatives does it exist or not we
don't know but it has real human fund
vibes i don't know how many of you guys
are for you know seinfeld fans but
there's an episode in which the george
costanza character
starts asking for donations to the human
fund which is fake it's just him it's
him it's you know money for people is
the slogan and the money just goes to
george and this is just apparently with
melania the continuing grift upon grift
upon griff that has been the trump
presidency the campaign he ran was a
grift
and then the presidency was a grift
and then the fundraising in order to
overturn it was a grift it's all a grift
and it now involves melania trump and uh
is the charity real or not well it's
certainly not registered with the state
of florida that alone is enough to make
it all against the law they will never
stop unless someone stops them i hope
that you will all join me
tuesday march 1 now just about 10 days
away for joe biden's state of the union
address this is expected to be one of
the most consequential state of the
union addresses in a long time for a
number of different reasons will joe
biden signal the end of the pandemic
phase of covid what will be going on
with ukraine russia what will be
signaled about the 2022 midterms which
themselves will be so consequential for
2024
major major uh state of the union
address we will be live on youtube
twitch and facebook starting one hour
before the speech i hope you will join
me and stick around today we'll be
taking some of your calls i'll be
reading some of your emails and so much
more to discuss
follow me on twitter at dpakman let me
know what you think about melania's
so-called charity we'll take a quick
break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is a viewer
supported program a listener supported
program you can sign up and get a
membership at joinpakman.com
extremely exciting thing to do you can
also use the coupon code wow 22 for a
discount
we are going to
take some calls we are going to take
calls via discord as we often do you can
find the discord at davidpakman.com
discord
let's talk to some people starting here
with alex from baltimore alex you're on
the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
all right
first i want to say i do thank my lucky
stars every day that i've knocked david
pakman thank you kidding of course
that's a predator right there
yes yes you are kidding again
okay so
uh one of the better faith arguments i
hear from your average joe and jane
against progressive policies would be
not ideological so much as
the american government and the
bureaucracy within it's just so bloated
slow
wasteful expensive
that
we don't even want to take the chance to
give them a bigger a bigger uh program
more responsibility because they're just
gonna screw it up and cost us a
ridiculous amount of money and it's
gonna be terrible um as a someone who
wants those policies implemented
is there
truth to that and how would you approach
dealing with that if it is true so i
think it's hard to deal in generalities
it's a very popular talking point just
to say the government's incompetent
don't give the government more stuff to
do the very very sounds very uh tight
neat and tidy as a talking point the
reality is that many of the proposals
from the left would actually simplify
the bureaucratic aspect of it for
example there are proposals as some say
to eliminate a whole bunch of small
means-tested social welfare programs and
put in place one program with either
only one bureaucracy for means testing
or no means testing at all that's a
dramatic simplification and you're
actually making it more likely that
government will succeed because it's a
much simpler program so number one a lot
of times you're not really giving
government more stuff to do and then
number two in terms of the bloat
argument many of the people advocating
for government to start doing certain
things are also saying government should
stop doing certain things so whereas
they want to grow one area they're
saying shrink another and so th that
argument sounds appealing but it's quite
literally untrue in many cases
yeah no i i get that and i'm
that's just more of me debating with
people
but i cert sometimes i do kind of agree
with them in certain things a good
example
like infrastructure and high-speed rail
in particular you hear stories that oh
they shut it down in california because
it was costing 25 million dollars a mile
meanwhile france who
is
quite progressive for the most part and
has lots of unions can do it for nine
million dollars a mile yeah and i mean
what you've got to remember is in
general europe is much better at trains
than the united states so when you're
better at something you're usually going
to do it more cheaply and number two the
government isn't building the rail
they're hiring people to do it so at the
end of the day it's actually private
industry that needs to get better so
listen it's very loud where you are so
i'm going to let you go i'm curious what
are you doing are you running a lathe or
something
uh no i i work at a weld shop i'm a pipe
fitter okay you're fitting pipe during
the call
oh well no i stepped outside it was a
little breezy it tried to get away from
me oh i see the pipe fitting would have
been even louder
well yeah there's lots of welding and
even more motors and then clanking and
pipe wrenches so it would have been
worse all right i appreciate it i
appreciate it thank you for the call
thanks david take care yep alex stepped
out of the pipe fitting area very very
important um let's you know last week we
tried to check in with eric from cancun
and he wasn't there so i'm going to try
once more eric from cancun can you hear
me
it's sunny right now um the thing i
wanted to tell you last week is what do
you think of traditions
what do i think of traditions i am not
in favor of traditions only for
tradition's sake
i don't find virtue in traditions in
principle but i have no problem with
specific traditions that are meaningful
to people
that's exactly what i want to tell you
because traditions are too commemorated
people that did things for us to
celebrate to improve our lives
and i still like traditions
it's like giving gifts and birthdays in
valentine's in holiday winters
then
i think that conservatives would be very
upset or worried that liberal is going
to get rid of those traditions but i
think that we're not really getting rid
of them only changing the way we do for
example in halloween i make cosmetics
for team fortress 2
and i think we should rethink about some
traditions like forcing women to stay in
the kitchen ignoring the opinion of
children and killing animals who pretend
to be brave and strong instead of taming
the beast like a real man also like
lieutenant dan want to die in vietnam
because his ancestors died in other wars
if you saw forrest gump
yes be a fantastic movie
and let me remember what the other thing
i was going to say oh i remember now
if you saw
you should remember just you see fiddle
in the roof the first song is called
tradition and there's a farmer called
tavian he says that in an athebica they
have traditions of how to pray how to
sleep how to eat to wear their molka to
pray to god and here's the most
important part he says when he is going
to tell us how this tradition started he
says
but it's a tradition and thanks to their
traditions they know what god expect
them to do
well eric you know you've touched in
such a short amount of time on the
weather
religion philosophy
film
i can't thank you enough for the
wide-ranging phone call
i want to tell only two things before we
cut
and for instance
oh my goodness
so the comments about our calls and they
say i have a cartoonish voice maybe if i
do my impersonation of mario like it's
me mario
can anyone tell nintendo to give this
beautiful caller a shot to work as a new
voice actor
eric from cancun thank you so much for
the call you've said it all and on that
note we're gonna have to go
let's speak next to
isaac
from
wyoming isaac from wyoming please
hello david thanks for taking my call i
appreciate you uh taking a chance on
somebody from wyoming i love wyoming
thank you
have you been to wyoming never
but i would like to go i hear that you
know there's like a big sky there and
stuff
yeah big sky and bad politics okay
um so i guess my question is it's kind
of silly because i sort of already know
the answer and honestly i just jumped in
here and um
admittedly not completely prepared but
uh my question is
do you have any plans in the future to
sort of hire your own investigative
journalists which i've seen you've been
doing
somewhat uh recently
and sort of just expand into a
legitimate news outlet
well we are completely illegitimate
currently and so your concern is
certainly warranted will we ever have an
air of legitimacy that's fair many
people ask me that uh that that's the
fair question uh no i know what you're
saying i mean we we we're a commentary
and analysis show we're we're not a news
reporting show and we don't we don't
pretend uh otherwise yeah maybe i'm i'm
always open to considering anything i
just think we have to think about like
as a small organization if we hire one
investigative reporter
can we really do something that we feel
is meaningful and we can feel good about
compared to entities with just
overwhelmingly more resources but i have
no opposition to it in principle
awesome uh
other than that uh
one more question as someone uh who's
more left leaning in our red state what
types of things would you recommend
for people in my situation to sort of
influence
politics in the state and push it
towards
the left more in many red states
where there's like a tradition of voting
for republicans but people are actually
open to different ideas getting involved
in ballot initiatives can be really
effective because rather than saying hey
vote for this democrat which maybe isn't
going to happen you can find ballot
initiatives that are
reasonable moves to the left
um that will not seem as scary to a
republican electorate and so i would
look at getting involved in ballot
initiatives whether they be about
campaign finance the environment
whatever's important to you
awesome yeah actually in wyoming there
there is an ongoing effort to create a
ballot initiative to legalize marijuana
um
that has thus failed so far because the
signature requirements are so
big you know we just can't get the
signature requirements yes
in any case thanks for talking to me and
uh i love the show all right thank you
so much let us know if uh you make any
headway there in uh in wyoming let's go
next to yannick from las vegas uh
yannick how's vegas these days
david pakman might can you hear me i can
okay i have one of those fears i always
see how uh
when the connection is bad how much it
uh upsets you so it saddens me yeah but
no our connection's solid right now
so i've got a lighthearted kind of funny
question for you so
i'm a financial advisor um
i have some clients who
i don't want to say anything too
specific but
imagine some of the craziest people you
see
on your show like they are cuckoo for
coco puffs yeah but
i help them manage their money okay so
some of my friends like joke around and
are like you're basically a candace
owens of wealth management so
my question is is like
what like what's your opinion on me
you know having those clients inevitably
listen if a financial advisor is so
uh
attached to
not helping people whose political views
are at odds with their own
it's up to you to decide i'm i'm only
going to manage money for progressives
like you could do that i don't have any
kind of opinion on that i mean i think
you know there's lots of jobs where i
mean could a mechanic say we only fix
cars for progressives like sure i could
but at a certain point it's sort of like
what are we trying to do and if your
goal is simply like okay let me build my
business as an advisor and just help as
many people as possible even if some of
those people will take their gains and
donate it to causes i don't want you
it's it's ultimately your call i don't
have any views
right i'm gonna tell them you said that
and also
funny note kind of not funny
during the last election i talked to a
lot of people
who were so deluded by this you know joe
biden is a communist joke you know he's
gonna crash the market
and i explained to them like listen
every article i'm reading that's coming
out
is basically saying like this guy's
policies are not gonna be much different
than trump anyway
and these
a lot of people i watch them sell
millions of dollars out of the market
and i'm like
well yannick i'm curious why you didn't
say something else
what if you told them the truth which is
stocks tend to perform better when a
democrat is president than when a
republican is president going back to
the beginning of the market i mean that
it's an undeniably accurate statement
what would they say if you told them
that
i think
i just think if you're getting into
specific facts like that they're just
gonna not
believe it essentially so they don't
trust you as a financial advisor
i think a lot of people let their
political leanings
over affect their investment decisions
right no i don't i don't doubt that but
i mean it would just be interesting if
if presumably they trust you to manage
their money and they go i'm thinking of
selling everything because a democrat is
going to win if you go oh no no the
market does fine under democrats you'd
think most people would be like oh all
right i won't do anything glenn
right i and i also think it's funny
because you know i talk with some of my
buddies and we're like
looking back i wonder like if i asked
these same people do like do i think
they'd be checked into reality that like
oh i was wrong or
are they gonna find some like oh the
democrats are they're rigging the stock
market too so
it it it's just a funny thing but
um i'm gonna get out of here my brother
i really appreciate the time i'm a
massive fan of your show so this this
was really an honor it's the first time
i ever uh jumped in the chat so
beautiful really and things are things
are okay in vegas i potentially will be
back there in a few weeks for my first
it's going to be my triumphant return
since the start of the pandemic
you know it's it's good so i just moved
i grew up in vegas i went to school
at georgetown university
i moved to new jersey and i've been
working
there ever since and then
i just recently moved back
to las vegas okay i went independent as
an advisor
the biggest
change but like besides that
there's like kind of everyone wears
masks and
excuse me there's never really been any
mask mandates in jersey
lately
so i'm kind of getting used to like
everyone here wearing the masks all the
time but
david people here are strapped to the
teeth and what i mean is
the amount of guns that people have here
it's it's just such a juxtaposition to
what i was used to in
new jersey
at this point
you know so just like seeing people just
open carry at the albertsons you know
what it is
it's just it's just a wacky wacky thing
if if you haven't seen it in a while you
know yep no doubt about it all right
yannick thank you for the call
a real honor my brother
there's yannick from vegas let's take a
very short break if you're holding don't
hang up because i'm going right back to
the phones in a moment
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow okay let's hear from a
few more people via discord
davidpakman.com
discord if you'd like to chat with me um
let's go
next to
um let's go to bob
from colorado bob from colorado you're
on
hey dave how are you doing i'm doing
well
yeah so i got a question i've been
seeing
news reports recently that um
you see a lot of the mega people
basically accidentally supporting
liberal policies
um
like i saw recently that
afraid exactly what it was but there
were attempts to break up tech
monopolies like facebook and twitter
and it had bipartisan support from both
the left and a lot of the mega people
yep
do you think
we might end up seeing a lot of
accidental liberal policies
kind of from
i don't want to say out of ignorance but
kind of out of ignorance yes i mean
what's going on is
a lot of these maga people are going
against their stated principles just
because they want to own the libs or
companies they perceive to be on the
left so for example like all these maga
people are like regulations bad
um
let's not regulate companies but then
like facebook bans their favorite
conservative anti-vaxxer and all of a
sudden they go
uh oh oh uh we gotta regulate that we
gotta regulate we gotta regulate
facebook all of a sudden um so uh i
think that at the end of the day they
don't really have an interest in
regulating companies they don't really
have an interest in enforcing antitrust
they've not expressed any interest in
that and i think what's gonna stop a lot
of this stuff from becoming legislation
is if they get close to saying we're
going to pass a more robust antitrust
infrastructure to break up some of these
tech companies their big funders in the
corporate world will say hey
if you do that it will also affect us
and then they'll back off of it that's
my prediction
so you don't think we're going to see
any big changes i really don't know
not if it depends on the maga people
like if politics get realigned then yes
but not not thanks to the maga people
okay and one more question um how do you
feel about the right to repair uh
i guess movement or bills that are pat
that are going on right now and do you
think we're gonna see anything
positive come out of that i am hopeful i
generally favor right to repair which
relates to a lot of different issues
including intellectual property and and
some other things generally speaking i
favor right to repair but on any
particular bill you know i have to look
at the bill to say for sure
there definitely seems to be bipartisan
support for that as well because i know
a lot of um rural
farmers and the like
um are supporting that
to you know be able to fix equipment and
all that yes absolutely yep no i think
it's a it's a worthwhile movement
okay thank you dave you answered all my
questions today all right thank you very
much there's uh there's bob great to
hear from bob
let's go next to
uh is it seido from spain saido from
spain
uh yes hello
uh can you hear me yes i can
hi uh
nice to meet you uh yeah it's so
uh yeah i wanted to ask a question but
i'd like to give a little bit of context
before so you guys can see where i'm
coming from
because seeing the lobby i might be the
only one not from the us right now
that's fine we just want a direct path
to your question you know we try to
avoid two monologues that are too
extensive
yeah uh basically i just wanted to say
that uh in spain i don't know how many
of you would be familiar with the
political context here but i tend to
tell my american friends a lot that the
right-wing extremists in spain would be
considered communists in the us
basically because a lot of their
propaganda uh turns around the
conservation of the of the social
government right
and it appeals you know to your older
frogs and stuff like that and um all
around europe you see many perspectives
that really aren't at all what you see
in the political context in the us and
uh i could give more context if you want
in several different issues but i
basically wanted to ask you
like are you aware maybe you as what
your americans call liberal or uh
americans in general
um
are you aware of how crazy and toxic uh
your politics or perceived are perceived
overseas
i am very aware of it i mean listen i i
have family in a lot of different
countries and so i am regularly getting
the feedback
that american politics are toxic and
insane we also have viewers you know 20
of our viewers are not in the united
states and so i get emails all the time
from people in denmark or spain or
anywhere saying it's insane what's going
on in the united states so yes i am very
much aware that this is not normal
here but i i know you are because as you
say you you speak with a lot of people
and you know many international people
know but do you think there is
so to speak a consensus within the
country no i think a lot of people have
no idea certainly there's a lot of
people that have no idea and uh that i
can't answer for them but there's many
people that don't know what's going on
in other countries
yeah fair enough
i would say it's it it's a bit
interesting from from the european
perspective
i think we see uh the united states as
being overly focused within itself
whilst the rest of the world
can know a lot about the us every single
country that has its size on the u.s
will probably be a complete mystery for
americans many americans are completely
self-centered in their news con
consumption for sure okay seville from
spain thank you so much for the call
i'm gonna leave you to the crinkly paper
or whatever you've got going on there um
very very much appreciated let's go next
where do we go next because there's just
it's it's
it's crazy what's happening on the
phones right now if you if you saw what
was happening on the phones
you would be uh
you would be shocked let's go to d baby
from is it alsace i don't know that i'm
pronouncing any of these things
correctly
d baby are you there it's it's all space
can you can you hear me yes i can
yes it it it's it's all says alsace
where is alsace
oh says it's on on the border of uh
france oh okay beautiful what's on your
mind d baby
well you know
i've just uh
i've just been a been a little little
little down lately
you know it just uh
just feels like we keep
we keep uh you know
this this inching inching progress
forward you know
it just feels like it's it's you know
one step forward five steps back
half a step forward eight steps back
i don't know it just it just seems like
we're we're going down i don't i don't
know do you do you have any any sort of
sort of uh any sort of
feeling that we're uh you know that this
trend is going to change are we having
can you give me some examples of the
steps forward and the steps back so i
would know what you mean
i mean i mean it it just uh i
i guess i guess one way to think of it
is is sort of if you look at what's
happening with inflation right now
you know like uh we we just
all these
d baby thank you appreciate the call
let's go
let's go to noah from california noah
you're on the air
hi can you hear me yes i can
all right hey david a long time listener
first time caller thank you uh i just
had a uh
question if if you've noticed i heard
you talk the other day that you said
crypto seems to be a trigger word for a
lot of people on the left
and i
feel like i've been
seeing that happen with tesla and elon
musk as well people trying to
uh
bag on his engineering of the vehicles
and saying that it's badly designed this
i mean i thought we were supposed to be
pro electric vehicle right yeah i just i
don't understand it
yeah i mean listen i i don't know that
i'm the right person to comment on this
as both a you know tesla vehicle owner
and long-time shareholder i quite
frankly couldn't care less about elon
musk i mean you know um
my car has been perfect there's no
problems with it it works fine every
feature works fine i've never had any
problem the car needs no maintenance
it has
you know we most vehicle manufacturers
doing electric vehicles
still don't have vehicles with range
anywhere close to what tesla has but i
do agree
that soon tesla's gonna have a problem
on its hands um one of those problems is
that i mean listen audi is better at
making cars than tesla
that's just the reality and right now
the audi e-tron gets 200 miles
per charge but later this year they're
going to have one that gets closer to
400 miles per charge once that's the
case
are people going to get the e-tron or
the model y i mean probably the e-tron
you know so so i think that there's
legitimate criticisms of the vehicles
there's criticisms of the company the
company is getting sued for certain
things and everything should all happen
i don't really care about the cult of
personality stuff i mean i think uh you
know elon musk needs to pay taxes and
elon musk needs to
do all the things everybody needs to do
but yeah for me it's like people just
get so emotional about this stuff it's
like i don't care about elon musk i
don't care about sergey brin or
zuckerberg specifically it's just sort
of like what are these companies doing
what are they bringing to the table are
they properly regulated etc elon musk's
wacky tweets yeah i find them stupid but
i just don't really care you know
right right i pretty much agree with
everything there i just have a quick
follow-up what do you think about these
uh electric trucks coming out i think it
was ford or chevron or something that
just released them uh do you have any
opinions about that would you be getting
an electric truck if given the
opportunity i don't need a truck i mean
you know growing up i had friends who
had pickup trucks and i would always say
what do you need the bed for and they'd
say oh every once in a while i move
something
i just don't i just don't need a truck
so i don't plan to get a truck but i
think it's fantastic and the fact that
there's such demand for the electric
f-150 bodes really well for electric
vehicle adoption um i i think it's great
i think we just need to be moving
towards electric vehicles period
completely agree thank you david for
answering my call my pleasure there is
noah with some very pointed questions
about uh tesla
and uh and other things
why don't we go next to
christian
from edmonton
uh hi david hello
um thanks for taking my call today
pleasure um i had a question about
election systems okay um so of course
i'm here in canada but i'm aware that
you guys have the popular vote
interstate compact
um attempting to you know change the way
you guys do your electoral electoral
system yes
um i understand it needs you know like a
bit under 100 more electoral seats in
order to become
active
but here especially in alberta but in
canada as a whole too we do have a
problem with gerrymandering
um just like you guys in the states okay
um as an example from our last election
in 2021
the ndps they're kind of like the
progressive party here
they receive 3 million votes which is
seventeen percent
and they got 25 seats but the block of
aqua which only is in quebec they don't
run in any other province yes they go at
1.3 million which is 7.6
and they got 32c
so
i'm it's more than just a population
thing
um
so
um when the trudeau government first
came into power in 2015 they ran on
proportional representation
but
i imagine they ran the numbers if we had
something like germany or japan and
quickly realized they'd lose a ton of
power
so they abandoned it
do you think making a change to the
proportional system or a popular vote
interstate compact would
fix gerrymandering or do you think it's
more systemic than that
are you saying in the united states
yeah in the us or if we in canada we
change to a proportional system there's
different these are two different things
that are in so i can only speak to the
united states in the united states
there's two different things going on
the national popular vote interstate
compact is a way to use an a national
popular vote to choose the president
without having to make a constitutional
change which is states just agree
we will give our votes to whoever wins
the popular vote so that gets us out of
the electoral college that's one thing
separately to deal with gerrymandering
which is within states in the u.s
setting up either i mean at this point
computers can fairly draw district maps
or setting up a non-partisan
you know
a district redistricting committee that
would solve partisan gerrymandering
within states and it's totally separate
from the national popular vote
interstate compact two different things
two different problems they would solve
okay so like if the interstate compact
came into effect because enough states
were able to just go on proportional
system
the the states that still gerrymander
like the southern states that do it
really bad they would still do that it
just wouldn't matter it had the
gerrymandering has nothing to do with
the presidential okay so the pres
the gerrymandering is for district seats
within states like
what is the what is the what is the map
of aoc's district
completely separate from how we select
the president all right my friend thank
you for the call very important issue
that is going to do it for calls today i
apologize if i didn't get to you but i
will try to do better next time
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
okay let's get into the mailbag for the
week many many many
many emails coming in over the last week
only a few can be chosen remember don't
abuse info
davidpakman.com really if you're
emailing every day
we're not seeing your emails they're
getting filtered
right into the trash uh actually no into
a folder in case law enforcement ever
has a concern about one of our viewers
it does happen
uh many different topics covered today
in the mailbag let's just jump right in
what am i even talking about let's start
with a message from peter
peter said don't underestimate gazpacho
david a number of extremist and
conspiracy researchers have brought up
the idea that marjorie taylor greene and
lauren beaubert's gaffes and spelling
mistakes are perhaps
deliberate ploys to spread their message
further
it is something to consider as every
time they make one of these mistakes it
goes viral some point you have to wonder
if they're doing it on purpose to get as
many eyes on their underlying message as
possible we already underestimated trump
the buffoon let's not keep making the
same mistake thanks peter yeah i think
it's completely reasonable to wonder
about that i think that there is
no way to argue that these buffoonish
gaffs are actually helping them build
support for any of these things i mean
the the gazpacho thing sure there are
some americans
who have been sort of
tricked or bamboozled into thinking that
there is some kind of
vaccine or mask gazpacho
gestapo but they're i mean they're
people aren't they're not really falling
for that the people who believe that
already believe it i don't think miss uh
pronouncing it as gazpacho is going to
bring people into the movement so i
don't think that they're that clever i
don't think that they're that smart and
even if it's what they're trying to do
to get attention to convince people by
saying gazpacho instead of
gestapo i just don't think it's working
uh at the end of the day and so i'm not
i'm not worried about that
joshua wrote in about bob saget bob
saget the comedian
who
died not long ago
we now know the cause of death was some
kind of trauma to his head
uh later went to bed and died
presumably due to some kind of brain
bleed that
became fatal while he was sleeping
joshua said so
now that bob saget's cause of death has
been released
don't you think it's time for candace
owens to go on tv and apologize for
saying it was due to the covet vaccine
just a thought
of course
of course candace owens the right-wing
provocateur
said in the days after bob saggett's
death
we got to be looking at the vaccines
here and it's not a conspiracy she said
we just we got to be looking at the
vaccines and of course there was no
evidence that
there was
uh uh
bob saget's death was related to the
covet vaccine
and there's no evidence that some of
them say thousands some say tens of
thousands some of them are saying
hundreds of thousands of people are
dying from the coveted vaccine there's
no evidence of any of that
but um
someone like candace owens doesn't
apologize and
if if she were
moral and decent she would
but their whole movement i mean listen
trump has never apologized for anything
their whole movement is based on not
apologizing and narcissism
something
very very much uh
present in trump's personality
and i would argue to a great degree with
candace owens as well narcissists don't
apologize they don't take responsibility
it's just what they do and uh we need to
we need to understand that kelly wrote
in kelly says
does religion make people susceptible to
bs
hey david hope you're doing well today
i'm a frequent listener couldn't help
but notice the craziest beliefs are
often held by people who will follow
their unhinged views up with a comment
about god or some aspect of religion
you've shown many examples of this on
your show
do you think holding religious or
supernatural beliefs
leads to people being susceptible to
believing other non-evidence-based views
stolen election or anti-vaccine let me
know your thoughts
so
the answer is yes and i want to try to
sort of be
like respectful in some sense and i
don't need to make this about religion
let me explain what i mean
we've interviewed on this show
experts in cults
experts in conspiracy theories
experts in conspiracism the psychology
of cults and conspiracies and on and on
and on and they have told us
it is very rare
that someone who is
eager
or susceptible to believe
non-empirically based claims like
conspiracy theories
are rarely only susceptible to one
and so the example that's often given is
we often think of flat earth as this
kind of benign
victimless silly little idea the earth
is flat and it's compartmentalized and
that's it but as our experts who we've
interviewed have told us and you can
find a lot of these great interviews on
our youtube channel on our website
a lot of the flat earthers also believe
in you know anti-semitic conspiracy
theories that
jews control the world and have mass
population control
uh delusions or you know whatever the
case may be and so
we know that it's true now it is up to
you to decide whether literal religious
beliefs like there was an ark that had
two of every animal
and they survived a flood that way it's
up to you to decide whether that's an
equivalent claim
or
um
god
would never
allow
kovad to be created so clearly china did
it or whatever belief it's up to you to
decide whether claims
like these that involve religion are the
same or not
uh it's not for me to tell you but i
think the trend we see
is that when you are willing to hold or
susceptible to believing one type of
non-evidence-based belief
you're almost certainly susceptible to
holding many of those types of beliefs
and there are such beliefs in religion
that fall under that category
steve wrote in
steve does not like a phrase that i used
he says hello sir
i'm hoping you could either stop using
the phrase put a pin in that or instead
instead say put that in a pin cushion
you don't put a pin in something to take
a break from it you put your pin in a
cushion to come back to it later please
do better says steve from tokyo steve
with peace and love
you're wrong you're wrong
the phrase let's put a pin in that to
temporarily stop talking about a subject
comes from
putting a pin
back in a grenade
before it explodes okay now i want to be
clear
you know this is like couldn't care less
or
minus well versus i might as well you
know all these phrases that people get
confused
uh the the idea here is you take a
grenade and you pull the pin
wow the grenade is now going to go off
you've got to resolve
that issue because the grenade will
explode
so when you say let's put a pin in that
what it goes back to is whoa we don't
want this grenade to explode right now
we don't know we need this grenade you
put the pin back in the grenade
now many grenades you can't actually do
that but it's
the idea is we're not actually going to
blow this up now let's put a pin back in
it and then we'll deal with the grenade
later that's the source of it steve and
i tell this to you with total peace and
love now is it possible that this whole
let's put that in a pin cushion i've
never heard that before i'm not saying
it doesn't exist but it sounds like it's
a different phrase different phrase okay
next charles wrote in
and said
i'm running into a lot
of pro-trump propaganda
on tick-tock
and on instagram reels
yes and i would go further
youtube shorts is a new
vertical video tick tock type format
it is all riddled with right wing
propaganda we are aware of this we've
talked to our youtube rep about it we've
talked internally
we in 2022 one of the things we're
focused on
is growing our tick tock following
using more of instagram's reels which
are sort of like a tick tock type format
and doing a lot of youtube shorts
because many of you have written to me
and they've said these formats are
dominated by the right so one of the
things we've been doing i'm taking a
look at my phone here
we've been focusing on tock where we are
now up to 72 000 followers a million and
a half likes
we're pushing tick tock big because it
is it is a right wing echo chamber in
the political space it's horrible and
you're absolutely right charles we're
going to keep pushing on tick tock reels
as well as youtube shorts okay sean
wrote in about waning literacy in the
united states sean says mr pakman sir
the depressing level of literacy on
display in your hate mail
isn't limited to david pakman's show
rage watchers believe me sean i know
sean goes on to say i've seen equally
terrible writing in various corners of
the internet that highlights social
media posts from members of the right
the herman cain award subreddit is an
obvious example but there are many
others i can appreciate that not
everybody is a naturally gifted writer
but in a developed country like the
united states it's scary that so many
adults have such a flimsy grasp of the
english language has it always been this
bad
and we're only now seeing it because
people have more public avenues to share
their written thoughts or are we just
getting stupider my guess is it's a bit
of both either way i only see the
problem getting worse as people continue
to demonize public schooling teachers
science and intellectualism
110
beautiful email from sean i think
there's two things going on i do believe
i don't want to say people are dumber
and in fact by various iq measures it's
not true but
look at
videos
of and this is always sort of fraught
when you do this and i know i'm stepping
into a minefield but
look at videos
of for example
high school and college students asking
questions to the late economist milton
friedman
and you will see
these i'm not going to say the average
student because this is clearly a group
that's interested enough to go listen to
milton friedman
the the level of how articulate
uh these these folks are and how well
spoken they are
compared to what you see
when ben shapiro visits a school and
takes questions it is night and day
so i think there is a change in terms of
how we
sort of expect people to communicate and
grasp on language i think that's a part
of it
but the last piece of the email is also
very very true
the right has spent decades now
demonizing public education
laughing off college's liberal
indoctrination and pushing this
anti-intellectualism all for their own
benefit because they know
we're more likely to convince less
educated people to vote for us because
our ideas don't really make any sense
they don't they don't say this but this
is my interpretation of it so there is
an education problem it it's
a very depressing email
that does uh
point to some major major issues that we
are dealing with
one other email from linda this is
another one of these uh phrases
linda says
i could care less is a derivative of i
couldn't care less
the latter is a direct statement the
former is sarcasm as if is implied
as an old person i remember when people
started saying i could care less
it was used only informally and was
considered funny you had to stop to
think and realize they were saying the
opposite of what they meant early on
some people would include the as if as
in as if i could care less i think like
most ironic expressions it was started
by some comedian the humor went stale it
sounds stupid people who use it will
correct it if necessary for non-fluent
speakers of english so they know it's
ironic or say it out of habit
if some young journalist wanted to
research this they could start with
stand-up comedy in the 60s and 70s i had
not heard that if this is true i i
as far as i know
the phrase is i couldn't care less and
when people say i could care less they
just don't understand it linda's saying
there is a historical basis for i could
care less and it was meant in jest to
mean the opposite of what is said
maybe i have not researched it i will
look into it last email today cedric
says dear david
i heard the booster shot enlarges the
prostate in black men
is that true
i am an african-american male
cedric i researched this
and found nothing of the sort
i found nothing that the vaccine
affects prostate size in any man
never mind specifically in black men
uh check with your doctor if you have
any doubts but i was able to find no
such information
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today
sign up at joinpacman.com you'll get
instant access to the bonus show you'll
also get commercial free audio and video
streams of the show available every day
six hours before the shows are publicly
made available sign up today and you can
use the coupon code wow 22 to get a
discount